يبدو ان الزواج مفيد لصحه القلب خاصه لدى
الرجال ينديهم دراسه حديثه كشفت عن ان
الذكور العزاب اكثر عرضه للوفاه من قصور
القلب بمقدار الضعف قارنه بالرجال متزوجين
او بالنساء في اي حاله اجتماعيه نقلت
صحيفه
احتمال وفاه العزاب بسبب قصور القلب اكثر
بمرتين من الرجال المتزوجين في حين لم يكن
لدى الرجال من المطلقين خطر متزايد للوفاه
مقارنه بالرجال المتزوجين وما تثبته دراسه
هو ان جنس الشخص حالته الاجتماعيه لهما
تاثير على حاله قلبه
[موسيقى]
هلا هي الدراسه امريكيه
واخذت جانبين يعني جانب اجتماعي وجانب صحي
بالنسبه للجانب الصحي
بزيد هرمون الكورتيزول عند الرجل باعمار
متقدمه فهذا راح يسبب نقص في اجهزه
المناعه ومن ثم حيزيد ضغط الدم ومن ثم الى
ازمات قلبيه هذا من الجانب الصحي خلينا
يعني ناخذ الزواج ما الغايه من الزواج
خلينا هيك نحكي بمفهوم كثير بسيط هو الانس
هذا المغزل الاولاني يعني هذا المغزى
الاول
عقل بجوار عقل وقلب مربوط بقلب وروح تداوي
ويد تداوي ونفسهم تطمئن وتامن يعني اذا
تحققت هاي الامور كلياتها في الزواج فاحنا
راح نحقق زواج ناجح
يعني الرجل الاعزب دائما بكون مشغول هلا
الموضوع احنا طرحناه بوقت كتير حساس لانه
الشباب اصبح عندهم عزوفه عن الزواج ليش
اما بسبب اقتصادي وهذا انحكى فيه بالتقرير
قبل شوي وبنفس الوقت اسباب شخصيه اوقات
بيكون عندهم خوف بكون عندهم قلق من انه ما
يكون مسؤول انشغاله في الوضع الاقتصادي
بانه يامن نفسه واوقات بيكون يعني شاب
طموح جدا ولازم نوضح كمان شغله انه طبيعه
الرجل
انتقالي ومحدد
ودقيق يعني مش مثل الانثى بتخترق كل
الامور ممكن بوقت واحد طيب بالنسبه للشباب
العزاب اللي يتجنبوا الزواج بسبب ما
يعتبروه خوف من المسؤوليه خوف من التقيد
خوف من الضغوط الاجتماعيه والضغوط الاسريه
ماذا تقولين له عم بقول له خذ التجربه في
مراحل جدا جميله ممكن تحرم نفسك فيها كل
ما كان عمرك اصغر عندك القدره على انك
تخود هاي التجربه بكل سلاسه وكل ما كبرت
بالعمر اكثر راح يكون اصعب لانه حيكون
عندك صعوبه في الاختيار لانه حتى اليوم
لما بده يرتبط به يعني بانثى هي كمان ممكن
تكون يا اما خاضت تجربه من قبل يا اما
حتكون هي كمان عندها صعوبه في الاختيار
بعدين الزواج فيه مراحل جدا جميله بالاول
بنكون زوجين شريكان بعدين بنصير ابوين
لطفل او طفلين بعدين ندخل مرحله المدارس
بعدين الاحفاد ومناكد على دراسه كمان
ثانيه انه الاجداد عمرهم اطول من الاجداد
اللي ما عندهم احفاد